explain to people who tiger global is
yeah so tiger global is is what they
call a crossover hedge fund it's a tech
focused crossover hedge fund
so they invest in uh public uh tech
companies mainly
so they have a very very large i think
it's like 30 billion plus i don't know
the exact number
they have a very large public portfolio
of tech stocks but they also invest in
private companies
just like you'd see in excel a kleiner
perkins a sequoia
uh a founder's fund any of us else
kind of you know private capital markets
folks invest in as well so they play on
both sides
and so normally a hedge fund
does the public markets or big buyouts
big big
chunks and then what we do in venture
capital tends to be
little bites early stage investing you
know
a couple hundred thousand for a seed
round couple of low millions for a
series a
and then series b things start to heat
up but we're in a hot market things are
getting very big
public companies are staying or
previously private companies were
staying longer before being public like
i don't know uber airbnb taking 10 11 12
years to go public
so is why is the tiger global
going downstream or i should say
upstream
going upstream to where we all hang out
at the source
uh by you know where the well is of you
know all this
amazing startup uh attention
when you think about the the evolution
of what i call like the venture growth
asset class and so that that's kind of
like everything from series b
so it's not you know two people in our
garage at this point it's it's kind of a
real business
all the way to the pre-ipo round and to
the ipo
um you know as you mentioned like the
first part of that sequence was startups
started being private for much longer so
gone were the days of like amazon doing
their series a next year the ipod
companies were now doing series b's here
c series d's
all the way to you know hig et cetera um
and at first the the folks really to
provide capital
to the entrepreneurs that were staying
private longer was like a mix of the
venture firms that were you know
climbing up the stack and
adding growth funds to their venture
funds so i think excel
uh you know had like you know raised
their first growth fund in 08
uh kleiner perkins uh you know brought
mary meeker over from morgan stanley and
started in
2011 their digital growth fund and then
you had kind of this like og
1.0 version of the crossover funds in
like tcv
and ga who are doing their thing all the
way you know investing in netflix in the
late 90s
and then you had kind of these
independent folks like maritek and ivp i
think that have been around since the
late 90s as well
working in this sort of part of the
asset class um but that was pretty much
it and
like for the last 20 years and
especially from from kind of 2010 to
2018
you needed to have a good brand like you
needed to make sure that you had access
to these entrepreneurs
but if you had a good brand and you had
investors that had a pulse
it candidly has not been that hard to
generate
really really good returns in kind of
the series b to series ipo because it
just hasn't been that competitive
so you raise your sears a from kleiner
perkins you're going out for your series
b
and it's like oh like i guess we'll just
go with like kleiner perkins again or
we'll go with clinton perkins in excel
there wasn't that much um competition on
the supply of capital providers so from
2010 to 2018
you have a fairly limited amount of uh
funds
doing just insanely well like it's not
been
very or it's been very very common to
see funds do
you know 3x money on money that means
you know you put a billion in you get
three billion out
whatever the fund size in that that's
the multiple of of how much you put in
but 3x funds 5x funds sometimes you know
10x funds even at the growth stage
have not been that uncommon um and
uh just like any uh you know free market
any competitive market if we learned
anything from econ 101
when there's excess profits like this
and by the way this is at the same time
while
people in the public markets 15 a year
irr
uh you know is best in class that gets
you the gold medal that gets you
um happy lps and you know i think like a
3x fund over
five years in the private markets that
equates to like a high 20s
you know percent irr and so the returns
were just much
much better in private tech um
than they were in in a lot of other
places
and it just wasn't that competitive uh
for for you know
15 ish years and so so the tiger then
decides they're going to formalize this
process
and scale it exactly yeah next piece of
this
is they realize wait a second you kind
of can't
lose if you do the series c d
e even maybe down into the series b and
let's be honest there's been an
inflation
what is a series a is now a series b
what's the series b
is now a certain c in terms of the
numbers so
but they are not designed to write 20
million dollar checks are they
they're not and and um they're not but
but you're absolutely right that
um yeah basically they it's a free
market it's a competitive market and so
if we know anything from econ 101
if there's excess profits in a market
you know competitors are going to come
in and compete the hell out of it
until it's at an equilibrium and so they
basically came in and said
wow you know there's nothing that
special or or
you know there's no moats in this market
that will prevent us from coming in
we know tech from investing in tech
since you know
uh 2000 or whenever they were founded
around then you know why don't we
come in um and do this and so yeah it's
like yeah like a 20 million dollar check
isn't that interesting for them but even
the 20 million check that they write
that opens them up to potentially do 100
200 300 million dollar check
down the line and by the way it's like
they're very best companies they still
hold zoom
they still hold snowflake i don't know
if they're able to get in those i don't
think they're able to get in those
before the ipo
but it's like they can also hold these
things and then put them in their public
portfolio
when they graduate from private to
public and so
you sort of described that they're
playing a different game than the vcs
who are here
you did a little math around it but just
to give an idea
and i think that um you know the
information
got some got some information from
pitchbook which is a database for people
who don't know of
adventure deals and uh right now if you
look at tiger's 2021 private tech
investments it's outpacing traditional
vcs handily
they've done over 60 deals two injuries
since 49 or so excel's 40.
sequoia is 32. now it's not a race to
throw money away here
but that you know doing double sequoia
kotu and dragoneer and kotu and
dragoneer are part of this cohort of
hedge funds dipping down correct yep
so in a way you have
the top venture firms doing bigger deals
and having growth and now you've got the
hedge funds coming down
how does the founder make the decision
here and how does it affect founders
this is this week in startups
after all not this week in capital
allocators although you and i as capital
allocators love
to talk about this wonky stuff what does
this do to a
you know founder with a company doing
you know 10 or 25 million dollars in
revenue
yeah so when you get when you're a
founder and you get to 20 10 to 25
of ar or you know if it's a software
business or
or you know other other sorts of revenue
at that point
especially these days you've probably
already raised your seed you've probably
already raised your a
and you've probably already raised your
b at that point you should probably have
the investors around the table that are
going to make up your board they're
going to be the people that you call at
3 a.m
when something's going poorly and that
are really helping you
from that kind of like investor
strategic level so often times
founders kind of get to the series cdef
phase of their business and they kind of
sit there and say
we don't really need more folks around
the table um
yet around the table being the board
room
yeah the boardroom or it's just like
there's honestly a lot of baggage that
comes with a lot of venture firms like
you know you as an investor at a lot of
these firms
when you invest in a company you want to
get involved because it also helps your
career as an investor
you want to come in you want to join the
board so you can go and tell your other
investor friends or other founders that
you're on the board of this company
um you want it's also your fiduciary
responsibility right so
the less cynical uh assessment of that
would be
yeah you know you you are responsible
for the money you're putting in right
that's very true yeah so that that is a
much more charitable interpretation
um than i but but that there is a lot of
i i think like the simplest way to think
about it
in a framework that that not many people
think about is is they think of
kind of investors at any stage on the
scale of like zero to ten
zero is not helpful 10 is like wow
amazingly helpful
and i actually think that the scale is
negative 10 to 10. like 10 is still very
helpful
zero's not helpful but an investor can
actually mess up a lot of course
the whole thing yeah exactly they can
mess up a business they can mess up a
boardroom in a thousand different ways
and so if you have something good as a
founder by the series c
you know oftentimes the product that
basically us
as venture capitalists are providing
what a lot of these firms are kind of
selling
founders just doesn't really resonate
and a lot of it seems like dead weight
or or there's a lot of risk that
the founder doesn't want to take on so
if you look at tiger and they're saying
we'll do the deal very quickly we'll do
very light diligence
we're not going to take a board seat you
basically will never see us again
but we're going to give you a very good
valuation and we're going to give you
low cost of capital
i think that's a product that can be
pretty attractive to some founders